[Music]
the lego movie was a huge hit when it
was released it got great reviews for
encouraging kids to be themselves and be
creative but the creators snuck in some
darker adult messages don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
just like this one be sure to hit that
notification bell and check out our
community section for more crazy fun now
let's explore these dark secrets
president business looks familiar when
the lego movie was being written and
animated in the studio's America was in
the middle of a presidential election
President Obama the Democratic candidate
was running from his second term the
Republican candidate was a businessman
turned governor named Mitt Romney Romney
was really rich and received a lot of
criticism for being out of touch with
most Americans many people were
concerned but having a businessman as a
president would be bad for the country
it was a close election and it was
pretty much all adults heard about for
months
Romney did not win the election but it
looks like he did in the Lego world many
people pointed out that President
business the bad guy who turns into Lord
business looks a lot like Mitt Romney
president business threatens Emmett and
the others with kragle
that's crazy glue which is totally not
awesome thankfully in the movie
Emmett helps President business have a
change of heart and be awesome and we're
glad we've never had a president
threaten us with Krazy Glue do you think
president business looks like Romney
regardless of who he resembles this is
not the only political message in the
movie kryptonite you might have to be a
real Superman fan to understand this
joke this joke was very quick and subtle
but it's a really dark Joe in the movie
lego Superman finds lego Green Lantern
annoying like really annoying he makes
his annoyance well known at the Master
Builders meeting but later on Superman
gets thrown into jail with the others by
President business he's stuck next to
Green Lantern and he is not so happy
about it he asks roommates how crazy is
that does anyone have some kryptonite
that they could give me if you aren't a
comic expert you might know that cook
tonight is an element's from the planet
Krypton that Superman's home planet
Superman is pretty close to invincible
but he can be destroyed by a kryptonite
so lego Superman is suggest
he'd rather destroy himself than be
stuck next to green lantern we've all
known annoying people but Superman is
being super dramatic here we aren't sure
this joke is as funny as the writers
intended it to be let's hope the sequel
doesn't have any real dark humor like
this joke communism this particular
political message is a bit confusing the
lego movie received criticism for being
both communist and anti-communist
huh maybe adults just read way too much
into this kids movie for a quick lesson
communism is when the government
controls all businesses so you can't
just go start a business business is
everywhere in the lego movie and if it
inspires us to not just fit into what
businesses want some people think that
this is an anti-business attitude and
encourages anarchy or going against the
government but other people say the
movie is actually pro-business and
anti-communism some critics have said it
glorifies big business and encourages
the classic American attitudes of hard
work and entrepreneurship the lego movie
definitely has a lot to say about
politics and economics but here the
message isn't very clear adults just
can't agree whether the messages are
about big business or good or bad then
again adults can't agree on a lot of
things anyway and it can't be too
anti-business considering Lego is kind
of a giant corporation right we will
stick to just laughing at the movie and
trying our best to be awesome
let's leave the economic philosophy to
other people so lonely Emmet is a great
main character he's funny and kind and
is definitely special but before he is
to believe to be the special he's
actually living a pretty sad life he's
got a life manual that tells him how to
be happy but his life just doesn't fit
the manual ah here it is instructions to
fit in have everybody like you and
always be happy
he knows all his neighbors by name but
they don't know his we love movies that
have us rooting for unlikely heroes but
Emmet is so sad and doesn't deserve to
be so lonely we feel so bad for him and
then he gets captured like he's some
sort of criminal
poor guy we all feel lonely at some
point in our life so Emmet is very
relatable it's really sad that he spends
so much time trying to live his life a
certain way and make friends we are glad
that he realizes he's awesome and
doesn't need to fit in with everyone
else the beginning of the movie tries to
use
humor to show how lonely and it is but
if you think about it he's living a
pretty dark life the end of the movie
totally turns his life around though and
Amit is always so positive
we wish he didn't have such a sad start
to his good life because he's just such
a nice guy
classic capitalism we've already talked
a little bit about all the political
messages hidden in the lego movie and we
figured out that no one can really agree
on a lot of it but really imminent his
friends aren't anti-business they aren't
anti corrupt business Amit doesn't have
super powers but he can still achieve
greatness through hard work creativity
and being resourceful the lego movie
sounds a lot like those old government
philosophers we learned about in history
class although the movie is quick to
point out the problem with bad business
leaders like president business it's
also about finding your place and being
your own person president business has
micro managers you may hear lots of
adults complain about bosses at
micromanage and this movie doesn't like
them either it values a person's
independence and skills over being
controlled it's really a movie about
freedom and while most of us just love
the movie for its funny jokes and
characters we bet a lot of working
adults really love it for this message
and we're sure some really hate the
message too oh well we'll just keep on
laughing that Emmitt and Batman and
Lando big brother if you're in high
school you might have read books like
1984 or a brave new world
these are super serious books about
societies where the government controls
everything if you ever hear about Big
Brother that means that the government
is always watching you even in your
private life you know kind of like the
old reality show but without a prize at
the end and the lego movie hints at a
big brother like government the lego
citizens are encouraged to basically be
the same and that being different is bad
there's a bunch of propaganda
encouraging people to buy the same cars
and to integrate another science says
conform it's the norm there are so many
rules like no gum and no marching band
and don't forget the life manual you're
always being watched to make sure you
don't go against the grain and then
Emmett and the gang try to fight back
they get thrown in jail and attacked
president business has an idea of how
things should be and he uses his power
to keep it that way we're just glad
there is a lot happier ending than some
of those scary books with the same
message
think that's dark keep watching to find
out the darkest secret the movies
creators don't want you to know brain
damage is no joke
do you remember Benny the funny little
dude who's obsessed with building a
spaceship spaceship spaceship spaceship
he spends the whole movie talking about
building one and his friends keep
telling him no but he finally gets the
chance to build one and help save the
day and he totally freaks out in
excitement vinnie is harmless but
definitely a little odd you might think
vinnie is just weird and excited but
Benny space helmet has a crack it is
totally possible that Benny has brain
damage from whatever cracked his helmet
while Benny's character is good for a
laugh brain injuries are serious and
often change people's personalities
forever we think it might have been
funnier without a cracked helmet poor
Benny we're so glad he finally got to
build a spaceship and we hope his only
major issue from his injury is his
obsession at least it didn't affect his
ability to build a totally amazing
spaceship Lando the flirt and one of the
mini throwbacks to the 1980s a LEGO
version of Lando Calrissian from the
original Star Wars movies is one of the
characters and the coolest part is that
he is voiced by the original Lando Billy
Dee Williams
but Lego Lando is a little different
from the old-school one this Lando is
such a flirt when he sees wyldstyle he
tries a totally smooth or totally creepy
pickup line might be the right galaxy
after all because I see that mint asks
he can take a ride on the Millennium
Falcon Lando throws him a suggestive
shoulder shimmy
it makes sense that Lando would flirt
with absolutely anybody after all he
does come from a galaxy far far away
with lots of people who aren't even
human of course neither wyldstyle or
Batman are all that interested in Lando
but he is such a flirt we doubt he even
cares
other than Lando the lego movie is
pretty wholesome on the flirty side bad
cop bad cop gives a whole new meaning to
the term two-faced he has a mean face
and is one of President business's
cronies but he's got a real internal
struggle and a whole other face you can
see that he is hiding a good cop face
but present business is the worst and
punishes him for losing Emmet and the
others he uses the kragle on bad cops
parents but the good cop side refuses to
finish them off so what does president
business do here
is the good cop face no mr. nice guy
only bad cop is left and he freezes his
own parents black cop is a metaphor for
the corrupt police officers he abuses
his position with police brutality using
deadly weapons but because most cops are
good guys he redeems himself later in
the movie good cop was more than just a
face and he draws a new happy face on
with a permanent marker we are so glad
he did what was right but the creator's
definitely were throwing in some
political commentary with his character
after all the lego movie was released
the same year as the Ferguson riots so
it was really relevant a giant
advertisement did watching the lego
movie make you want to go home and play
with your Legos or maybe made you want
to buy some more that's exactly what
Lego wanted to happen sure the movie
didn't tell you to ask your parents for
Legos but the movie was really one big
advertisement and it worked
Legos have been around for decades so it
made parents nostalgic for the hours
they spent building things as kids it
made kids add Legos to their Christmas
lists the movie rekindles working adults
love of play as Will Ferrell's character
lightens up to play with his son the
lego movie wasn't a girl's movie or a
boys movie it appealed pretty equally to
both genders Legos cells jumped 14
percent after the movie released and
increased 25% the year after they
capitalized on the success and release
movie themes toys and video games three
years later they released a Lego Batman
movie and are releasing a sequel to the
first movie in 2019 the lego movie was a
marketing success every time you watch
it you're basically sitting through a
giant commercial who is your favorite
Lego character from the lego movie let
us know in the comments be sure to like
this video and subscribe to the things
for more awesome content
[Music]